With just 12 days to go to the start of the football World Cup in Qatar...
…there are renewed doubts about the suitability of the Arab state...
...to host the tournament.
Now Sepp Blatter, the former president of FIFA, football's governing body,...
…said that he'd always been of the view that awarding the World Cup to Qatar...
…had been a mistake, as the country was too small, he said, to host the event.
And there's been worldwide criticism of remarks by Khalid Salman, a former Qatari...
…professional footballer, now a World Cup Ambassador...
…who said that homosexuality was "damage in the mind", in his words,...
...and warned gay people that they would have to accept the country's rules...
…when they visit it.
Qatar has been consistently criticized for its stance on same-sex relationships,...
…its record on human rights, and its treatment of migrant workers.
Our sports correspondent, Jane Dougall, has this report.
In Qatar, this could see you in prison or even given the death penalty.
This protest is to pressure FIFA ahead of a World Cup in a country...
…where same-sex relationships are illegal.
And just days before the Tournament begins an ambassador for the World Cup,...
…Khalid Salman, has told a German broadcaster that homosexuality is Haram,...
…which means forbidden, but he went further, denouncing same-sex relationships.
But do you think gay is Haram?
It's Haram.
Because, why is it Haram?
I am not one big Muslim but, it's Haram. Why?
Because it's damage in the mind.
At this point, a World Cup official steps in to bring the interview...
...to an abrupt halt.
His words have upset many, including Helen Hardy,...
…founder of LGBT football team, Manchester Laces.
It was so definite and what was said, and so deeply offensive...
…and I don't think it could be taken any other way...
…so, we're quite clear on how they feel about LGBTQ+ people.